[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come here
carries
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Emily then mr. president I suggest the
absence of a board will call the roll
mr. Alexander miss Baldwin mr. Barroso
mr. Bennett mrs. Blackburn mr.
Blumenthal mr. blunt mr. Booker mr.
Bozeman mr. Brahn mr. Brown mr. burr
Miss Cantwell mrs. capito mr. Cardin
mr. Carper mr. Casey mr. Cassidy
miss Collins mr. Coons mr. Cornyn miss
Cortez Masto mr. cotton mr. Cramer
mr. Crapo mr. Cruz mr. Danes mr.
duckworth mr. Durbin mr. NZ miss Ernst
mrs. Feinstein mrs. Fisher
mr. Gardner mrs. Gillibrand mr. Graham
mr. Grassley miss Harris miss Hassan
mr. Hawley mr. Heinrich miss her oh no
mr. Hoeven mrs. Hyde Smith mr. Inhofe
mr. Johnson mr. Jones mr. Caine mr.
Kennedy mr. king
miss clove achar
mr. Lankford mr. Lahey mr. Lee mrs.
Leffler mr. mansion mr. markey mr.
MacConnell miss mcsalley
mr. Menendez mr. Merkley mr. Moran Ms
Murkowski mr. Murphy mrs. Marie mr. Paul
mr. Perdue mr. Peters mr. Portman mr.
Reid mr. rich
mr. Roberts mr. Romney miss Rosen
mr. rounds mr. Rubio mr. Sanders mr.
sass mr. schat's
mr. Schumer mr. Scott of Florida mr.
Scott of South Carolina mrs. Shaheen mr.
Shelby miss cinema Miss Smith missed a
banal mr. Sullivan
mr. tester mr. Thoon
mr. Tillis mr. Timmy mr. Udall mr. Van
Hollen mr. Warner
is Warren mr. Whitehouse mr. wicker
mr. Wyden
[Music]
mr. Jung
mr. Jung
a quarter Rule four of the Senate rules
on impeachment and the United States
Constitution
the presiding officer will now
administer the oath to John G Roberts
Chief Justice of the United States his
order the escort committee will now
conduct the Chief Justice of the United
States to the diets to be administered
the oath
where you will do I'm gonna do a little
spirit senators I attend the Senate in
conformity with your notice for the
purpose of joining with you for the
trial of the President of the United
States I'm now prepared to take the oath
will you place your left hand on the
Bible and raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear that in all things
a pertaining to the trial of the
impeachment of Donald John Trump
President of the United States now
pending you will do impartial justice
according to the Constitution and the
laws so help you God I do
thank you very much at this time I will
administer the oath to all senators in
the chamber in conformance with article
1 section 3 Clause 6 of the Constitution
and the Senate's impeachment rules will
all senators now stand or remain
standing and raise their right hand do
you solemnly swear that in all things a
pertaining to the trial of the impeaches
in the chamber in conformance with
article 1 section 3 Clause 6 of the
Constitution and the Senate's
impeachment rules will all senators now
stand or remain standing and raise their
right hand do you solemnly swear that in
all things a pertaining to the trial of
the impeachment mr. Alexander
miss Baldwin mr. Barroso mr. Bennett
mrs. Blackburn mr. Blumenthal mr. Blunt
mr. Booker
you
mr. Bozeman mr. Brahn mr. Brown mr. burr
you
miss Cantwell mrs. capito mr. Cardin mr.
Carper
mr. Casey mr. Cassidy Ms Collins mr.
Coons
mr. Cornyn miss Cortez mast Oh mr.
cotton mr. Cramer
mr. Crapo mr. Cruz mr. Danes mr.
duckworth
mr. Durban mr. NZ miss Ernst mrs.
Feinstein
mrs. Fisher mr. Gardner
mrs. Gillibrand mr. Graham
mr. Grassley was Harris miss Hassan mr.
Hawley
you
mr. Heinrich is Hirono mister Hoeven
mrs. Hyde Smith
you
mr. Inhofe mr. Johnson mr. Jones mr.
Caine
mr. Kennedy mr. king his club achar mr.
Langford
mr. Lahey mr. Lee mrs. Leffler mr.
mansion
mr. Markey mr. McConnell miss mcsalley
mr. Menendez
mr. Merkley mr. Moran MS Murkowski mr.
Murphy
mr. Portman mr. Reid
mr. rish mr. Roberts
yes mr. Romney mr. Rosen
mr. rounds mr. Rubio
mr. Sanders mr. sass mr. schat's
mr. Schumer
mr. Scott of Florida mr. Scott of South
Carolina mrs. Shaheen mr. Shelby
mrs. cinema Miss Smith miss Stabenow mr.
Sullivan
mr. tester mr. Thoon mr. Tillis mr.
Timmy
mr. Udall mr. Van Hollen mr. Warner MS
Warren
mr. Whitehouse mr. wicker mr. Wyden mr.
young
you
is recognized any senator who is not in
the Senate chamber at the time the oath
was administered to the other senators
will make that fact known to the chair
so that the oath may be administered as
soon as possible
sergeant in arms will make the
proclamation hear ye hear ye hear ye all
persons are commanded to keep silent on
pain of imprisonment while the House of
Representatives is exhibiting to the
Senate of the United States articles of
impeachment against Donald John Trump
President of the United States the
majority leader is recognized mr. chief
justice for the information
hear ye hear ye hear ye all persons are
commanded to keep silent on pain of
imprisonment while the House of
Representatives is exhibiting to the
Senate of the United States articles of
impeachment against Donald John Trump
President of the United States the
majority leader is recognized mr. chief
justice for the information that the
summons be issued in the usual form
provided that the President may have
until 6:00 p.m. on Saturday January the
18th 2020 to file his answer with the
Secretary of the Senate which will be
spread upon the journal and the House of
Representatives have until 12:00 noon on
Monday January 20th 2020 to file hmm to
file its replication with the Secretary
of the Senate found I ask consent that
the Secretary of the Senate be
authorized to prep as a Senate document
those documents filed by the parties
together to be available to all parties
is there objection
without objection so ordered I ask
unanimous consent that if the House of
Representatives wishes to file a trial
brief they'd be filed with the Secretary
of the Senate by 5:00 p.m. on Saturday
January the 18th 2020 further that if
the president wishes to file a trial
brief it be filed with the Secretary of
the Senate by 12:00 noon on Monday
January
2020 further that if the house wishes to
file a rebuttal brief it be filed with
the Secretary of the Senate by 12:00
noon on Tuesday January 21st 2020
finally I ask consent that the Secretary
of the Senate be authorized to front as
a Senate document all documents filed by
the parties together to be available for
all parties is there objection
without objection so ordered I ask
unanimous consent that and recognition
of the unique requirements raised by the
impeachment trial of Donald John Trump
President of the United States the
sergeant-at-arms shall install
appropriate equipment and furniture and
the Senate chamber during all times that
the Senate is sitting for trial with the
Chief Justice of the United States
presiding the appropriate equipment
furniture and computer equipment in
accordance with the allocations and
provisions are now send to the desk and
asked that they be printed in the record
is there objection without objection so
ordered
I ask unanimous consent that the Senate
sitting as a court of impeachment
adjourn until Tuesday January the 21st
2020 at 1:00 p.m. is there objection
without objection so ordered the Senate
sitting as quart of impeachment is
adjourned until Tuesday January 21st at
1 p.m.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know this is the hardest part you're
almost there we love you start it on
Thursday at 10:00 Thursday at 10:30
still going strong and it's Saturday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I understand like no one from us yet
they this guy